kids are always encouraged to read
during these summer months away from
school but with many libraries closed
some have lost access to free books
now one small community in southwestern
virginia has developed a work around
with the help of wing the drone delivery
company launched by the parent company
of google
it's become the only place in the world
where kids can check out a book and have
it delivered
from above chris vancleave explains
eight-year-old lilly withers is in a
hurry racing to the backyard to check
out a library book
i'm like oh i have to get ready to grab
the book because we have a lot of birds
in this area
and i sometimes feel like the birds are
just going to swoop down take it
take it from a drone christiansburg in
the southwest corner of virginia
is the u.s test city for google's drone
delivery venture wing
you were thinking if i can get my advil
and my burrito delivered by drone why
can't i deliver
library books yeah so we initially were
talking about the program as
a way to bring kids and their summer
reading together
kelly pasek was one of the first to sign
up last fall the montgomery county
public schools librarian immediately
reached out to wing with the idea
we need to continue to find ways to
bring
reading and to bring books to our
students you took that
quite literally absolutely i found a new
way to do it when kovitt closed
schools and libraries wing flew in to
help the students
this is just one way that we can kind of
help bridge that gap about 600 kids live
in wings delivery area
they can send in a book request
electronically to pasek working on her
own time this summer she finds the book
packages it and drops it off at wing
where the book is weighed
because the drones can only carry about
three pounds then hoisted into the air
and race to kids like lily about a five
minute flight away
it gets her reading again she had
stopped reading you know for a while and
we've been stuck home from school
a touchless delivery from above of more
than 50 books and counting since
mid-june
and kids don't have to return them until
in-person classes resume
we think it's the only place in the
world where you can get library books
delivered by drone
it's it's a bit like an airlift meets a
reading rainbow yes that's right
i have students that are my regular
readers that are requesting books
but if i can get a book to a student
because they were excited to get a drone
delivery then that's also a success for
us because now they've got one more book
than they had before
it's really cool but the only thing that
is that you can't thank the librarian
for getting you the books
do you want to say thank you now yes
thank you librarian
thank yous have also come in pictures
like these of excited students
but pasek's real reward is knowing kids
like lily
are getting lost in the pages of a news
story
however it's delivered for cbs this
morning saturday
chris van cleave christensburg virginia